Hey youtubers it’s charlie and since we’re
starting to learn more about the flash tv
series I thought it would be fun to talk about
some of the best flash comic book stories
they could use on the show.
Just to be clear season 1 just like Arrow
will be all about the origin story.
Barry Allen will be learning about his powers
trying to solve his mother’s murder and
once we get to season 2 it will be about learning
the higher purpose.
I feel like a lot of super heroes are selfish
with their powers right after they get them,
at least until they get the Stan Lee speech,
with great power comes great responsibility.
Yes this is DC and that was Marvel, but every
super hero gets a version of that speech at
some point in their genesis.
Wouldn’t it be great if it turned out that
John Wesley Shipp was the one to give Grant
Gustin the Uncle Ben speech?
Even if it turns out he’s not Jay Garrick.
Real quick before we get started, if you didn’t
see yesterday I said I’d be doing Marvel
movie videos every Tuesday from now on.
But if there’s really interesting DC stuff
to talk about I’ll do it then too.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So let’s get started, here are my top 5
Flash stories.
Number 5 - The Blitz Storyline.
This like most of the good flash stories in
recent memory is Geoff Johns re-writing the
origin of Professor Zoom.
Or just Zoom in his pre-New 52 incarnation.
What’s really cool about the story is that
Johns makes Wally West, the current Flash
at the time, complicit in the origin of his
greatest nemesis.
And he ties it all back to the trial of Barry
Allen from the 1980s comics when he killed
the second Professor Zoom.
This version of the Zoom character is Hunter
Zolomon the third version of the character.
In the tv series it’s going to be Edward
Thawne, a riff on the second Professor Zoom
Eobard Thawne.
Number 4 - The Return of Barry Allen.
This story happened in the same year that
they killed Superman in Death of Superman
and Bane broke Batman’s spine in Knightfall.
So bringing Barry Allen back from the dead
almost went unnoticed.
It was a huge deal though.
The character had been killed during Crisis
on Infinite Earths and was out of the comics
for about 7 years.
The story is all about Barry Allen rediscovering
himself and Wally West who had become the
new Flash, learning to share the spotlight.
This is a really good comic to read if you
want to learn about the physics of the Speedforce.
It’s a little like Mythbusters Flash Edition.
It’s also got this crazy twist ending that’s
really awesome.
Number 3 - Rogues Revenge.
This is an awesome Flash story that focuses
on the Rogues during the events of Final Crisis.
It picks up right after they kill Bart Allen
and gives you a really deep cut of what it’s
like to be a Flash villain.
They’re a lot like the Suicide Squad in
that they’re not crazy evil like Zoom, but
they’re not good people either.
It’s totally possible that they could do
a story like this in one or two episodes.
Minus all the details of Final Crisis, just
a villain centric arc for an entire episode.
It would be like Arrow just doing an episode
that mostly followed Slade instead of Oliver.
Number 2 - Flashpoint.
This was the last Flash title that Geoff Johns
wrote and the last Flash book before the New
52 reboot.
The story can be hard to follow if you’re
new to the idea of how time paradox’s work,
but essentially Zoom changes the past creating
a new timeline and Barry Allen fixes it but
in the process makes himself a living paradox,
essentially erasing himself from existence.
But the solution to the problem is really
ingenious because they use it to explain how
in real life the DC, Vertigo and Wildstorm
comic book universes now exist together in
the New 52 reboot.
So it solved this meta problem that dc comics
had with all their imprints and characters
existing separately and now they’re all
part of one big shared universe, just like
all the marvel characters exist in the same
universe.
and my Number 1 Flash Story - Rebirth.
Rewind to the beginning.
This story was actually the start of Geoff
Johns second run on The Flash with Ethan Van
Sciver.
They had just rebooted Green Lantern and done
the Sinestro Core War, which by the way is
amazing.
The story is all about the second return of
Barry Allen after the events of Final Crisis
and includes characters from all over The
Flash’s 70 year comic book history.
It also treats the different types of powers
each version of The Flash had in interesting
ways.
For instance, Jay Garrick’s super speed
is different from the way Barry Allen and
Wally West are affected by the Speed Force.
So Rebirth reimagines the shared Flash Universe,
but remember this was from 2009, so since
then the Flash has been rebooted again for
the New 52 universe.
Personally though these 5 stories are what
I consider to be the best, and just as a rule
of thumb you can’t go wrong with stories
written by Geoff Johns.
He’s doing Justice League right now.
So now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite Flash story is and let me know
if you think they’ll do a lot of comic book
story-based episodes during season 1 of the
show or if they’ll try to change a lot of
things.
Like I said earlier, I’ll be doing Marvel
Universe videos every tuesday from now on
unless there’s epic Superman Batman news.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’m still reserving Wednesdays for Arrow
and Flash whatnot.
I am working on a big Captain America video
for tomorrow.
Right now click here for my first preview
of the Flash tv show and click here to learn
all about Arrow Season 3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!